[Music]
hey lola
checking in from idaho i'll call you
again from twin falls okay
i miss you hug joseph for me
hey you all right yeah i'm all right see
that's what i need to do what mom tells
you to do
walk against the trap what you're 15 all
right i'm 45 you think i don't know what
the hell i'm doing out here yeah no i
don't
that's why i'm with you
[Music]
uh my name is joe bell and i'm on a walk
for change
i'm walking across america to speak out
against bullying
i'm getting picked on by these guys at
school why is that i'm just i'm
different i'm just
that's not an answer jade no i cause i'm
gay we're gonna let nature take its
course all right it'll all be fine
it'll work itself out you know what it's
not gonna work itself out
my son 15 years old took his own life
because he was bullied
this is your fault you knew he was
suffering i mean what did you do
you're feeling nervous well there's a
lot of things i've learned out here
nobody but me for company so it's been
hard to come to know
stop just be careful all right
don't ever let them steal your choice i
still feel jaden's presence
i thought being out in the wild would
help you be a man what does that mean to
you be a man
i was afraid for you all right we were
all afraid for you
knew before he died that you loved him
and accepts them that's what matters
isn't it i never let him know he was
okay i got to live with that
i saw your eyes behind your head i don't
think i keep going
i just want to come home if you're
walking for jade then you let jayden let
you know when it's time to come out
maybe if you walk long enough and far
enough you can find me again
i failed my son and it's too late for me
to make things right with him
if there's this one thing you remember
today you make it this
hold on to the ones you love and you
love them for who they are because you
may not get that chance again
[Music]
foreign